what's going on guys this is rob and
let's talk about shang chi because this
movie was
beautiful oh my god it was so unique now
here's the funny thing you wouldn't know
it unless you were absolutely looking
for it so i don't know if this really
falls in the realm of a spoiler but
there's an easter egg as it pertains to
galactus and a reference to kane the
conqueror the real question is can you
guys spot it so here's the cool thing
first things first the movie like i said
felt beautiful right it was just it was
unique and it was phenomenal and it just
it felt great one of the big fears that
i imagine a lot of people had including
myself my fiancee mariah is that well i
wouldn't necessarily say we were going
to see like full-on whitewashing
throughout the film that the beauty of
what could be a movie highlighting asian
culture would kind of be synthesized
down to fit the mold of a marvel
cinematic universe movie that was not
the case right the beauty of asian
culture was on full display for the
world to see and it was phenomenal right
here's a crazy thing the soundtrack
added to it in an incredible way the
soundtrack we got in the trailer was
really cool you don't really hear that a
lot over the course of the movie some of
the fight scenes you hear it but in
terms of like the interim scenes when
you're exploring a new area when you're
seeing different things especially when
the beauty of asian culture is being
highlighted it's a wholly different feel
do you know what it reminds me of the
the whole soundtrack for the second half
of the film after they discovered talo
it reminds me of crouching tiger hidden
dragon that's what it reminds me of if
any of you guys ever saw that movie you
know exactly what i'm talking about if
you didn't see crouching tiger hidden
dragon you're doing yourself a severe
disservice it's probably one of the most
beautiful movies about asian culture
that was ever made in the history of
hollywood it's it's it's phenomenal but
nonetheless the soundtrack for the film
was fantastic i loved that like the
mandarin was not your stereotypical
villain right he wasn't like obadiah
stain or like the guy that created
taskmaster i can't remember his name
because he was forgettable like it
wasn't like any of those guys right the
mandarin was in a lot of ways humanized
i thought he was just going to be like
i'm the mandarin vlog i'm bent on world
domination and i've tricked you shang
chi
roll credits like i thought that was
going to be the the overall film but it
wasn't the mandarin was complex and he
was great and it was amazing you know i
i love i loved that honestly and this is
this is the craziest thing is the
craziest thing to say as much as i love
shang chi he didn't really feel like the
star of his own movie i mean obviously
he was there there's really no way to
contest that the way the film unfolded
he was what i mean by that when i say i
don't feel like he was a star of his own
film is everybody else was awesome in
that movie they all had something to
offer they all brought something unique
whether it was a feel or it was a
character's plot progression whatever
the case happened to be the only person
that we didn't really get a whole lot of
feel for was a guy in the mask who
trained shanxi right i don't remember
his name he's got a name in the comics i
don't know honestly he was a throwaway
character he only saw for about 10
issues so i can't really remember his
name but nonetheless it was cool to see
him right he was kind of there for a
little while but everybody else right
especially the mandarin the relationship
between shanxi and the mandarin himself
that was very complicated and it was
beautifully handled and beautifully done
now having said all that right love the
movie let's get to the really really
good stuff right let's get to this
really really cool stuff that i'm sure
you guys clicked on this video for first
things first i hear these rumors or see
these rumors flying around the internet
right now tahloe is technically not one
of the seven capital cities of heaven
but it could be now here's the deal for
those of you guys who aren't familiar
with the seven capital cities of heaven
these are basically seven particular
dimensions or kingdoms that exist in
marvel comics and traditionally their
doors only open for the rest of the
world to access once every 88 years now
at the same time what you also have is
called the tournament of the heart of
heaven or when they all merge into a
singular kingdom is referred to as the
heart of heaven that matters that was
actually covered during immortal weapons
why does all this matter because one of
the seven capital cities of heaven is
kunlun where danny rand became iron fist
and in fact where a lot of people were
iron fist before danny ran basically
it's a it's it's one of these things
that people are theorizing that tylo
could be one of these cities and it
could be a way to kind of expand out
beyond the shang chi mythos and actually
wrap in the dany random mythos without
us having to worry about getting that
terrible version of his character from
netflix because that version sucked but
even if it's not necessarily one of the
seven capital cities in the comics as we
know with the movies they change things
up if i'm being honest with you guys if
they were to replace talo with one of
the seven capital cities from the comics
it would likely be ping li that's the
one they would probably replace it with
because ping li is basically just an
island kingdom right it's exactly like
the way that you saw toddler depicted
that's basically ping li in the comics
biggest issue you have is talo is an
actual place in marvel comics and it
actually exists but they could just wipe
out ping li entirely and just take take
talo as it exists in the comics and
switch it over to being ping line in the
marvel cinematic universe and there you
go right and it works perfect which also
brings us to our next point right the
easter egg as it pertains to galactus
the dweller and darkness now at the time
that i am making this video or sometime
during today i'll actually be uploading
a video called the dweller in darkness
explained over comics explained that
will make you an expert on the character
but to give you the quick and dirty
explanation here the dweller in darkness
is the reason galactics exists in marvel
comics so the way this worked is that in
the universe prior to the maine marvel
universe that galactus was a guy named
gallon and his universe was basically
dying he didn't really know why but what
you end up finding out in the adventures
of the x-men mini-series is that there
was a being who was basically a fearlord
somebody akin to nightmare but less
powerful named the dweller in darkness
and the dweller in darkness had actually
fractured the imcron crystal which is a
hallway of doors for the multiverse and
quite literally started sucking the
whole multiverse in now ultimately the
dweller in darkness was defeated but the
collapse of the multiverse couldn't be
stopped and so gallon had actually
merged with the sentience of his
universe and then was kind of reborn
with the new multiverse and a version of
galactus in every single universe so
that's where you get galactus from in
marvel comics now obviously this is not
an explanation
of where galactus comes from in the mcu
that's why i say it's just a nice little
easter egg but it does give us our first
real depiction of a fearlord in the
marvel cinematic universe somebody that
comes from the same stock is nightmare
even though the dweller in darkness is
not as powerful as nightmare is
nightmare will basically be very similar
to what you see from the dweller in
darkness in shang qi the big difference
is that nightmare will likely look like
a person he does in the comics there's
no reason to believe he won't in the
movies in the the comics the dwelling or
darkness really looks like a giant
demonic dragon type being so there
really isn't a whole lot of
differentiation between how the
characters are depicted in the comics
versus the movies but again our first
real fearlord it's cool it's very very
exciting right because this sets us on
the path and really it's marvel kind of
slowly introducing us to the idea of
extra dimensional lords demonic entities
beings different things like that who
could just wreak untold power across the
entirety of the universe now in relation
to the king the conqueror
reference which i'm sure a lot of you
guys
probably clicked on this for
let's talk about the mid-credits scene
for a second the post-credits scene is a
post-credit scene right it's basically
shang's sister taking over the entirety
of the her father's kingdom right and
that's basically it but the cool thing
here is that the mid-credits scene is
basically them like wong and like bruce
banner and carol danvers analyzing the
ten rings that shane she had in his
possession and the important thing here
is wang says there's nothing about this
in the codex of the sorcerer supremes
and that in turn you've got carol
danvers who's like i've never seen
anything like this in the universe and
bruce banner's like i have no idea how
this works but once they break it down
they realize it's a homing beacon it's
sending out a signal to someone now
where is this signal being sent from
okay a couple of things to keep in mind
just because a sorcerer supreme exists
does not mean the sorcerer supreme is
aware of everything in the world is
aware of every single artifact in
existence and if the rings of the
mandarin were one of these things that
just kind of existed on earth and nobody
had ever really used them until
eventually the mandarin came across them
and then took them from whatever it is
he got them from there'd be no reason
for the sorcerer's supreme to look for
it because it's not as though somebody's
running around with the ten rings just
like obliterating all things in
existence and causing all kinds of
problems and then it boils down to a
huge problem between like the ancient
one and whoever's wielding the ten rings
of the mandarin right it's not
necessarily that way they literally
could have just been sitting in the side
of a cave and then the mandarin
eventually found them right even in the
beginning of the movie we're not given
an indication of where it is that the
mandarin got these rings right all we're
really told is that there's just myths
and legends of how he got his hands on
them we just simply know that he has
them now let's look at carol danvers
carol danvers says there's no technology
like this across the entirety of the
universe that's important bruce banner
doesn't understand it he's like this
technology is way beyond me the reason
why i think nobody knows anything about
these rings is because technically
they don't exist yet they haven't been
invented yet
these rings are from the future
and they belong to kane the conqueror
advanced technology the ability to
harness the elements to achieve all
kinds of different things i think
everything you saw the entire use of the
rings over the course of this movie was
virtually nothing right it's like a some
primitive person picking up a shotgun
and using it as like a baseball bat or
like a blunt object right to just beat
somebody over the head with completely
and blissfully unaware of its intended
purpose whatever that purpose happens to
be we know in the comics that if the
rings are utilized to their full
potential you can control all kinds of
elements you can control like dark force
energy to literally just encase people
in darkness seemingly for all eternity
you can do all kinds of different things
right these rings while not necessarily
on the same part or the same level as
somebody like doctor strange can get you
pretty darn close to him right so these
rings are capable of incredible things
assuming that they're taking their
nature in the comics and bringing it
over to the movies having said that i
think it belongs to kane the conqueror
now the question has to be asked if the
rings are from the future and they
belong to kang how do they end up in the
present day well if they end up
following the logic of marvel comics and
they bring that into the movies at some
form or fashion that came the conqueror
at one point traveled into the past on
earth and became a pharaoh by the name
of rama tut because if you look at the
rings themselves where they are glowing
blue and they do seem to kind of
indicate maybe letters and things like
that when you actually look when you
look at the actual inscription on them
the blue parts really seem to only
indicate uh characters from asian
culture but the overall writing on the
side doesn't lend itself to any one
particular culture it doesn't look like
it's hieroglyphics from egypt it doesn't
look like it's from asia it doesn't look
like old english it doesn't look like
any of that stuff right it really has no
particular symbology that ties it down
to any one particular culture across the
world because i don't think it exists
yet right i think that lends a strong
credence to the fact that no one in the
universe carol danvers has never seen
anything like it in the entire known
universe and we have to believe that
given her access to the advanced
technology of the cree they've probably
catalogued virtually every culture in
the entirety of the universe so surely
she's like well let me just go back and
access our library of information and
she can't find anything right wong with
the all the information he has at
sorcerer supreme basically covers the
existence of every magical artifact
across the entirety of earth along with
pretty much all the dimensions that
they've explored and that they know
about and of course bruce banner is
pretty intelligent is he on par with
iron man no is he on par with reed
richards he'll know but he is still
pretty smart and if he can't figure it
out well then seemingly nobody could
because i don't think the rings exist
yet i don't think they've been created
by kang king will create them in the
future king will use them for whatever
the purpose happens to be he'll end up
in the past and egypt is rama tut he'll
do whatever it is that he wants to do
over there who knows what his motivation
will be for doing that the rings will
somehow get left behind and they will
just sit on earth until they're
discovered by the mandarin who uses them
in his primitive understanding of
advanced technology to basically start
conquering different societies and
expanding his fear of influence across
asia running all the way up until the
modern era so with that being said guys
let me know what you think down in the
comments section did you love the movie
did you enjoy the movie let me know
and i'll catch you all later
peace